>>> WITH THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
JUST TWO WEEKS AWAY TODAY, MANY
VOTERS ARE NOW RETREATING INTO
THEIR LEFT CORNER AND RIGHT
CORNER BUT IT'S THE FOLKS IN THE
MIDDLE, SWING VOTER WHO IS DON'T
FIT NOTELY AND DEMOCRATIC OR
REPUBLICAN LABELS THAT OFTEN END
UP DETERMINING THE OUTCOME OF
KEY RACES.
CASE IN POINT, JUSTIN AMASH.
HE WAS THE FOUNDING MEMBER OF
THE HOUSE FREEDOM CAUCUS, THE
FIRST MEMBER TO COME OUT AGAINST
TRUMP DURING HIS FIRST
IMPEACHMENT.
HE DECIDED TO LEAVE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, BECAME AN
INDEPENDENT, LEFT CONGRESS AND
BECAME A LIBERTARIAN.
WHAT DOES JUSTIN AMASH MAKE OF
THE STATE OF THE POLITICS OF THE
NOVEMBER ELECTIONS?
FORMER MICHIGAN CONGRESSMAN
JUSTIN AMASH JOINS ME NOW LIVE
IN STUDIO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WHEN YOU LEFT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IN 2019, QUOTE, I'VE
BECOME DISENCHANTED WITH PARLY
POLITICS AND FRIGHTENED BY WHAT
I SEE.
TWO PARTY SYSTEM DEVELOPED INTO
A THREAT TO AMERICAN PRINCIPLES
AND INSTITUTIONS.
TWO YEARS LATER DO YOU FEEL THAT
SAME WAY STILL?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY, AND I DON'T
THINK ANYTHING CHANGED
STRUCTURALLY TO MAKE IT BETTER.
THE YOU LOOK AT WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN, SPEAKER PELOSI,
AND IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING, IT'S THE
SAME DYSFUNCTION, THE
BIPARTISANSHIP.
IT DOESN'T WORK THE WAY OUR
CONSTITUTION WAS DESIGNED.
>> WHAT WOULD NEED TO HAPPEN?
DO YOU THINK THE PARTIES ARE
BEING PULLED TOO FAR TO THE
EXTREMES?
DO YOU THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
LESS GERRYMANDERING?
WHAT CHANGES.
>> WITH RESPECT TO
GERRYMANDERING, IF YOU HAD
RANKED CHOICE VOTING I THINK
THAT WOULD HELP.
BUT I DO THINK YOU NEED
STRUCTURAL REFORMS IN CONGRESS,
AND REALLY THAT CAN ONLY BE
HANDLED AT THE TOP, SOMEONE LIKE
SPEAKER PELOSI OR WHOEVER THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE IS, KEVIN
McCARTHY, WHO I DON'T THINK WILL
DO THIS, NEEDS TO DECENTRALIZE
THE CONGRESS.
RIGHT NOW IT'S TAKE IT OR LEAVE
IT AND I THINK THAT LEADS TO
PERFORMATIVE POLITICS.
WHEN YOU CAN'T DEBATE POLICY YOU
DEBATE PERSONALITY AND IT
HAPPENS ALL TIME.
>> WHEN PEOPLE ARE WATCHING TV
ADS THAT SAY, CONGRESSMAN JONES
VOTED WITH NANCY PELOSI 99% OF
THE TIME, HONESTLY, THE KINDS OF
THE VOTES THAT HAPPEN IN
CONGRESS ARE PRETTY BAKED IN.
MOST PEOPLE VOTE 95% WITH THEIR
PARTY, IT SEEMS.
>> YEAH.
WHEN I FIRST GOT TO CONGRESS, WE
HAD MORE VOTES ON THE FLOOR,
MORE AMENDMENT VOTES.
WE WERE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE.
MEMBERS TODAY CAN'T OFFER
AMOUNTEDMENTS ON THE HOUSE FLOOR
THAT WILL BE TAKEN UP.
THE LEADERSHIP BASICALLY SAYS,
YOU HAVE TO SEND IT TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE, THEY'RE GOING VET AND
IT DECIDE IF YOU CAN HAVE A VOTE
ON IT.
THERE ARE FEW AMENDMENTS ON THE
FLOOR, AND THAT MEAN YOU DON'T
GOAT DIFFERENTIATE THE MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS MUCH.
>> OR IMPROVE LEGISLATION.
WHEN I GOT IN THERE, YOU MIGHT
HAVE 100 AMENDMENTS ON A MEESE
OF LEGISLATION.
SOME PEOPLE THINK THAT'S TOO
MUCH BUCK WHAT'S NICE IS YOU
GOAT KNOW WHO YOUR MEMBER OF
CONGRESS IS.
YOU GET TO DISCOVER THE OUTCOME,
REPRESENT PEOPLE.
YOU ALL GET IN THERE.
YOU HAVE THIS JUST GIANT PIE OF
MATERIAL, AND THEN YOU PUT IT
TOGETHER AND SEE WHAT COMES OUT.
>> YOU LIVE IN MICHIGAN,
BATTLEGROUND STATE, LOT OF KPI
RACES.
THE GOVERNOR'S RACE IS
COMPETITIVE.
WHAT DO YOU SENSE?
YOU HEARD MY MONOLOGUE EARLIER
TALKING ABOUT HOW IT SEEMS RIGHT
NOW DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
FEEL AS THOUGH REPUBLICANS ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE A PRETTY
GOOD NIGHT IN TWO WEEKS WHAT ARE
YOU PICKING UP OUT THERE?
>> THAT'S ANY -- I THINK THE
REPUBLICANS WILL TAKE THE HOUSE.
SENATE IS A CLOSE CALL, BUT IT
SEEMS INCREASINGLY THEY MIGHT
TAKE THE SENATE AS WELL.
I'M NOT SURE THIS IS A GOOD
THING FOR REPUBLICANS IN THE
LONG RUN, ESPECIALLY FOR KEVIN
McCARTHY IF HE'S SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
>> WHY IN.
>> IF YOU HAVE A SMALL
MAJORITY -- IT COULD A MARGINAL
WITHIN FOR REPUBLICANS, IN OTHER
WORDS THEY HAVE A 10 OR 15 SEAT
MAJORITY.
THE THAT'S THE CASE, THEN YOU
HAVE A FEW MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
WHO WILL BASICALLY BE ABLE TO
DICTATE THE PROCESS TO KEVIN
McCARTHY, WHICH COULD BE GOOD
FOR THE OVERALL FLOW OF THE
HOUSE.
MIGHT OPEN THINGS UP, BUT IT'S
GOING TO MAKE KEVIN McCARTHY'S
JOB MISERABLE.
>> AND KEVIN McCARTHY, NOT
SOMEBODY THAT YOU HAVE A
TREMENDOUS REGARD FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP SKILLS.
>> RIGHT, NOT SOMEONE I ADMIRE.
I THINK HE'S BASICALLY CRAVEN.
I THINK HIS GOAL IN LIFE IS
BASICALLY TO EMPOWER HIMSELF.
I'VE SEEN HIM GO THROUGH
CONGRESS NOT KNOWING WHAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT, SWITCHING POLICY
POSITIONS ON A DIME.
WE SAW THAT WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHERE ONE DAY HE'S SAYING
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR JANUARY 6th.
ANOTHER DAY HE'S SAYING TRUMP IS
GREAT AND HE'S NOT RESPONSIBLE.
SO, YOU KNOW, HE'S A GUY WHO'S
ABOUT HIMSELF, AND I THINK
THAT'S REALLY BAD FOR CONGRESS.
WITH YOU WHEN YOU LOCK AT HOW
CONGRESS FUNCTIONED UNDER PELOSI
OR SPEAKER RYAN OR BOEHNER, IT'S
BEEN A CLOSED OFF PLACE FOR A
LONG TIME.
IF WE DON'T FIX THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO KEEP HAVING PEOPLE LIKE
McCARTHY.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
DEBATE IN YOUR HOME STATE
BETWEEN WHITMER BE THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE, TUDOR DIXON.
LET'S LISTEN TO A QUICK SNIPPET.
>> SHE REFUSES TO ACCEPT THE
OUTCOME OF THE LAST ELECTION.
SHE HAS NOT YET SAID SHE'LL
ACCEPT THE OUTCOME OF THE NEXT
ELECTION.
WHEN SHE SAYS SHE ACCEPTS THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE, SHE IS AN
ELECTION DENIER AND NEVER SAID
THAT JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY WON THIS
LAST ELECTION.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
GRETCHEN WHITMER AND HER
DEMEANOR TONIGHT COMING AFTER
ME, CALLING ME AN ELECTION
DENIER.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE
THE WAY THE EVENING GOES.
BUT I'M WONDERING WHEN SHE WILL
SAY SHE CAN'T RUN WITH
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR GARLAND
GILCHRIST ANYMORE, BECAUSE I
BELIEVE HE IS ALSO AN ELECTION
DENIER.
>> ALL RIGHT, JUST TO BRING
PEOPLE SOME FACTS HERE, TUDOR
DIXON IS REFERRING TO A 2017
DETROIT CITY CLERK RACE.
AND IT'S TRUE, WHITMER'S
GOVERNOR ASKED FOR A RECOUNT.
AFTER THE RECOUNT, HE ACCEPTED
THE RESULTS, AMBASSADOR ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT FROM TUDOR DIXON WHO
SAID SHE DOESN'T BELIEVE
JOE BIDEN WON THE PRESIDENCY IN
2020.
THIS IS A SICKNESS.
>> I THINK IT'S A PROBLEM, BUT
DEMOCRATS KEEP HANDING THEM
AMMUNITION, SO I THINK THAT'S
ALSO --
>> HOW SO?
>> YOU DO HAVE PEOPLE LIKE STACY
ABRAMS AND OTHERS OVER THE YEARS
WHO HAVE SAID THINGS, AND
THEY'LL LATCH ON TO ANYTHING.
EVEN IF THERE'S A LITTLE BIT,
THE REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
LATCH ON TO IT.
IT'S PARTISAN POLITICS.
IT'S NOT THE SAME DEGREE, NOT
THE SAME LEVEL.
MIGHT BE A FEW IN THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY AND REPUBLICAN PARTY,
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT HAPPENS IF
ONE PARTY GIVES THEM A LITTLE
BIT, THEY'LL SAY, YOU'RE JUST
LIKE US.
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE.
WE'RE TRYING TO DEFEND DEMOCRACY
THE SAME WAY YOU ARE.
>> DIXON IS ONE OF NINE
CANDIDATES ON THE BALLOT IN
MICHIGAN THAT QUESTIONED THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION,
INCLUDING NOMINEES FOR SECRETARY
STATE AND ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I KNOW YOU, AND I THOUGHT YOU
WERE AN INTERESTING LEGISLATOR.
YOU'RE SUCCESSOR, PETER MEYER,
THE SAME.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IN MICHIGAN IN
I GUESS IT'S THE SAME THING
THAT'S GOING ON NATIONALLY.
>> IT'S THE SAME THING
EVERYWHERE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT PETER MEYER'S
RECENT RACE, HE CAME CLOSE TO
WINNING, RIGHT?
IT WASN'T LIKE A BLOWOUT BY THE
TRUMP BACKED CANDIDATE.
SO I THINK THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY, AN OPENING FOR
PEOPLE TO MOVE THIS BACK IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION IN SELECT PLACES
IN THE COUNTRY.
NO EVERYWHERE -- MAYBE WEST
MICHIGAN IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
A LOFT OTHER PLACES IN THE
COUNTRY.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S A
WHOLESALE EVERYWHERE TRUMP
BACKED CANDIDATES ARE GOING TO
WIN, AND YOU SAW THAT IN PLACES
LIKE GEORGIA AS WELL AND OTHER
RACES WHERE THERE ARE SOME